people who enjoy riding in uber cars
will be able to buy shares in the
company for the first time this morning
the stock market debut is expected to be
one of the largest initial public
offerings ever with the company valued
at more than 82 billion dollars that is
about twice the size of the Ford Motor
Company
'über stock will start trading at $45 a
share CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what this means
for uber drivers and their customers
hello Jill no so Cooper hasn't turned a
profit how is it why is it such a big
deal well you know it's losing billions
of dollars a year it's amazing and so
you say to yourself well why would
anyone buy a company that's losing money
and it's really the premise of becoming
what they're calling the Amazon of
transportation we do ride sharing and
ride hailing right now but we'll add
scooter rental bike rental will add
Freight delivery will add autonomous
driving and so all of these things
together might give over the chance to
become the platform for anything
transportation related the one area of
their business that makes money food
delivery and they're gonna hope to build
on that as well well shareholders what
was sorry well ultimately want a company
that makes profit just as john was
talking about so will we see a rise in
prices well I'll tell you something
that's amazing experts tell me it's
probably 10 years before this company
actually makes money so I think
customers could see the price start to
creep up right you know this is how it
works we buy a subscription service we
get hooked on it
we love that drug and then they raise
the prices and we start saying okay that
could happen I think fairs will likely
rise for both uber and for lyft it's the
gateway drug to all kinds of other
behavior drivers they have struck
against uber what's what does this mean
for drivers well uber in this offering
is putting aside some money for cash
bonuses for drivers and it's based on
how many rides that you've completed but
I have to be honest with you I mean many
of these uber drivers are not in the
position to use that cash to go ahead
and buy stock so I think it's kind of
silly drivers are going to keep the
pressure on
remember these older drivers they're
contractors they are not employees and
as such uber doesn't have to pay a whole
host of benefits if that were to ever
change in the few
the financials of this company would be
very different you should give them some
shares just give them right don't give
you a cash bonus give me a charge you
shares invest in the company's long term
future
I think the drivers would be very happy
with health insurance and a 401 K so who
benefits most here
the founders obviously the early
investors are clearly the winners here
some of the big investment banks that do
the underwriting and you know honest to
god when you look at all these numbers
it is not it's it's hard not to really
see that a lot of these drivers are
trying to claw their way to make a
living and there will be instant
millionaires and billionaires early and
you know again a lot of the employees as
well so it's hard not to have that
feeling as you walk away from a deal
like that but the drivers are still
saying what about us yes absolutely
about us oh thank you